bonjour je m'appelle angelica larricq
bord société a&g création je suis
organisatrice et coordinatrice de
mariage j'ai créé mon entreprise le en
novembre 2013
et ça fonctionne pas mal alors
l'originalité et la force c'est la
qualité de mes prestations de la
coordination ce que j'emmène à mes
clients en faites pas ce que je cherche
du haut de gamme et il y en a très peu
sur la réunion c'est pour ça que je me
suis principalement intéressée à l'autre
challenge parce que ça me permettrait
déjà au côté organisation bas voire du
monde avec moi au moins une assistante
et puis ben ça l'était enfin comment
vous dire ça élargir mais mon entreprise
sur la décoration
bonjour bertrand payet je présente ma
société mettre sa propre 97,4 la société
a été créée au 1er octobre de l'année
c'est une société d'entretien de surface
en hauteur et plus spécifiquement pour
les panneaux photovoltaïques
alors c'est un entretien très
particulier nous nous sommes renseignés
auprès des précurseurs dans les panneaux
photovoltaïques donc les allemands et
les américains qui ont mis au point
depuis maintenant plus de 25 ans
un système bien spécifique de nettoyage
de ces différentes surfaces et nous
avons fait rentrer une machine l'année
dernière qui consiste à rendre de loup
puis de l'eau du robinet totalement pur
principe mécanique qui peut être aussi
chimiques non on évite le côté chimiques
dont c'est un souci de l'écologie on va
dire pour respecter un petit peu le
cursus de l'énergie renouvelable
donc voilà on a des particules d'eau qui
sortent d'une machine bien spécifique ce
qui permet d'avoir un entretien
optimale de ces différentes surfaces
je me fais rimbert un état j'ai 28 ans
et j'habite à saint benoît en fait et
jouissant du tri à bras fusil d'un jeune
et urbaine et
et voilà ça fait presque deux ans je
suis de sept domaines en fait benjamin
que son indice pour l'instant et
j'envisage d'investir dans repas ou deux
premiers nécessité parce que j'ai mon
entreprise est au dessus du même j'ai
travaillé 18 mois cdd et après bien
fatigués chez travail parce que toute
assez maintenant c'est par piston donc
du coup ben j'ai décidé de créer mon
entreprise
voilà mais c'est pas possible les
clients ben il motive à au 2d continue
parce que si nos clients mais ça faisait
que ben et les gens aiment s'est pas
fait bah quoi là